season four worth it it's gonna be on
the Internet that's right yeah 8:00 a.m.
Pacific Standard Time 12 episodes this
time we're in for season 4 so you know
yeah March 18 it's gonna be a fun time
the trailer right now season four huh
how do we get here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Cheers the season for we're going to a
special place
road trip skite your hip Holdren some
people aspire to own luxury cars I want
to pay a premium to get that
hand-cranked meat slicer I get some of
that no I love seeing food get made you
start salivating in anticipation it's a
pretty busy for the movies in Korea
mommy's grandma always makes food with
their hands that's what I'm doing with
love you know it's actually the first
full-service vegan restaurant in the
history of Harlem we wanted to make a
difference in the community it seems to
be a hit because everybody loves it whoa
I've kind of developed the diet of a
bear force-feeding every day and then I
go to sleep for six months then I do it
again and that is the wet season oh yes
[Music]